leaving the tramp was one of the first
movies I ever saw in theaters
so naturally I loved it when I was a
little kid the story of an upper-class
female dog that comes across a low-down
scroungy male dog is about as typical as
it gets at first they don't like each
other but a few situations forced them
together and as they get to hang out
more they really decide that they were
meant for each other there's some
differences too this usual story that I
like like the fact that I enjoy when
they first see each other it's not love
at first sight like so many other Disney
films if anything he just sees her in
passing it just strikes up a
conversation it's not even a pleasant
conversation he's talking about how a
baby's gonna take over her life and that
she's never gonna be the center of
attention anymore and then he just
leaves honestly if you didn't know the
story going in you probably would have
guessed they'd be together by the end I
sort of like that there's also a bunch
of clever little touches to like I enjoy
how the dogs interpret everything like
how the main character thinks that the
name of her owners are Jim dear and
darling simply because that's what they
call each other all the time
poor darling in the kitchen Jim dear as
Disney films go it's cute
nothing that's spectacular it keeps your
interest you want to know what's gonna
happen but there's no real big surprises
or any phenomenal bits of animation or
well just anything that really stands
out that much but for what it is it's a
decent film it did give us that great
science on though I don't know is that
racist now to amateur but it's the one
song everybody hums when they're leaving
the theater so that's gotta count for
something
we are stymie if you don't be it is nice
that they don't go for a straight-up
villain in the movie or any of those
four story cliches well except maybe one
or two but they're pretty downplayed the
movie is pretty much just a series of
moments but they're nice moments and I
don't recall them ever being really
boring so overall I think it's okay I
don't think it's one I'll be watching
over and over like the other Disney
films but it holds up decent if you're a
dog lover or if even not check it out
it's worth an hour and a half of your
time
Oh